hi everyone it's jerry i'm on chess.com
right now i'm going to play one game
10
2
time control against the beast
ah and that is not the way i wanted to
see
the computer start okay
usually gives me trouble yeah this f5
move
so weakening but what can i do against
it to try and take advantage of these
squares the e6 square in particular
okay
decision time
knight c3 or c4 first
he's gonna fianchetto the bishop
should i try to negate that right away
with b3 and bishop to b2
hmm
or just opt for very quick development
i'm going to shoot for c4 knight c3
right there to be expected okay let's
get
try and focus on the queen side
development
b3 bishop to b2 and i have to be careful
of this queen a5 move
queen a5 knight e4 and bishop to g7 can
cause this guy some problems
hmm
i wonder this knight is a bit misplaced
he goes to b4 i'll give him a quick kick
and if he goes to c7
not sure where his next great
square is
let's see
hm
knight f3
most natural
i wonder however if there's a reason to
play him somewhere else
like knight h3 into f4
it's more time consuming but
might be a worthwhile square to be at
anticipating this uh
this advance in the weakening of e6
not sure clearly
it's nice to have some time to think
though
not rushed here
b3 not not yet at least
b3 bishop to b2
i just don't know how about
let's go with the knight f3
okay i mean i could still try and get
here with knight g5 into that square
and
i play a3
because i want to follow up with queen
c2 i don't want to run into knight b4
stuff
let's get queen in here
i'm trying to get an e4 in one shot
and i think i'll be able to manage that
let's go forward with it right now
e4 i could get out of this pin
i was going to say if pawn takes knight
takes bishop here i could get out of it
with bishop d3
so queen here there's bishop here
okay
that's actually a bit inconvenient i
think
okay let's drop back just one step
hang on for a second
i don't have very much choice i think
there's gonna be queen check bishop d2
and knight before no
it's not going with that
okay
let's develop
without this guy around my night could
turn out to be a giant pest yeah no
wonder why you're going there
without that light square bishop my
knight would be a monster on that square
so he's trying to take this guy out
i see
i should probably castle right now
or
try and jump in here
hmm
what about h3
yeah i think i might like h3
um bishop takes queen takes can't castle
so easily
i'll try that
you gonna give me the bishop pair
uh-huh
no castling for you
all right
gotta block that
now what
okay
rook b1
gotta defend
i'm reluctant to say i like this
position even though i do like this
position but
the computer is
sneaky
under six minutes
plenty of time
queenie
two what's this knight doing
he is a clown
how about
i think more about moving forward
queen g4
no
queen g4 i'll be inviting queen b3 with
tempo i don't want to allow the queen to
enter my position with tempo
i will be content with
this cool move queen d2 consolidating
aha
so you have to go about
your development in an awkward way
now
oh for a second i think i thought the
king was going to run over here
and the rook here is simply there to
defend and it makes way for castles and
i actually can't even queenside castle
because of queen e6 and i pick up the
rook
i'm tempted to play b3
just so i don't have to deal with queen
here
let's do it
kingside castle next aha
you know what i'm tempted to not even
castle kingside
i'm looking at h4h5 stuff to
have the
light square bishop be felt
let's shoot for it let's go break down
these light squares
maybe i'll castle now
maybe i'll castle no
that f2 is it
uh maybe not
well i was going to say this but there's
queen a5 picking up this pawn and it's
not just any pawn it allows knight b4
okay four minutes and change
i'm gonna castle
king here okay
what about this right now
let's go for it
follow through
okay f2 is getting hammered
to check or not now i want to eventually
have a tempo against this so
i need to do something about f2
i could do that with this
no queen a5 with checks so now
huh
that is
different
am i not just winning a pawn here what
am i missing give me that bishop and
give me this pun
wow
really
careful though
let me take this guy first
i don't want knight c5 to be played
let's keep him out of there here here
knight c5 would be a bug
that's right you go into defensive mode
uh is it too crazy to think about g3
king g2 rook h1
hmm it's getting ready for a pawn push
okay
how about i play queen g4
yes
move forward keep pressure on something
there would be a tempo in this direction
anyhow
and i'm pretty sure i just want to take
let's do it rook takes maybe rook b here
oh
now that i did not expect c5 takes takes
and then i get to this square
i feel like i have the computer on the
ropes
it feels like that let's try this
less than three that's right
look at how i'm pushing the computer
around a little bit
i could take this pawn now nice
i think i'm gonna do that queen takes d
let's go for it i'm up a pun
i like being up upon
here let's go for a queen trade
wait a second
yeah
queen trade
about queen check here
hmm
kind of like that
no
here rook block no you can't block like
that
queen check let's think i have two
minutes
uh it's about to be simplified a bit
more i like that this rook is in a pin
he can't feel too comfortable
queen check queen takes queen pawn takes
i'm on the rook and then i take here
then i'm ready to take here
let's go here
check
ah
where are you running to king
what are you so afraid of
hmm
alrighty
what about
taking a queen
and then
hmm
okay i'm still up a pawn but
i don't feel as comfortable
let's see
ah rook to e1 i want to get rid of that
pesky knight
let's try this get my other rook work
working
okay
and that night is gonna be a bug
it's definitely gonna be a bug
yeah that was a bit silly
hmm
okay
let's try this keep the knight out f4 i
guess knight d4
bishop here
hmm
i kind of want to stay out of harm's way
don't know a great square for my bishop
let's
let's play here i guess
let's try knight d4 threatens knight e2
uh-huh
what am i missing
bishop takes pawn
what
bishop takes pawn where's the i don't
see it i gotta i gotta grab stuff
oh
that move
um
what's the big idea there
oh boy we're gonna find out
11 seconds
yes
i see that let's throw the bishop in the
corner
hopefully he's not as tactically
vulnerable there yeah oh man tricks
tricks everywhere
oh more tricks
knight here was threatened
there goes a pawn
hit a knight
seven seconds
ah i can't get rid of that pesky knight
i loved my position i really did ah
there goes a bishop i'm down anyway
oh
man
i was so close
ah let's go back here
you see
ah man i think right around here i felt
good
felt good man
let's go back
c5 there
should probably i should have just
take take right away if i could do it
over
i think i would have tried that
yeah
why didn't i
yeah because you know what
um i wouldn't have had to deal with the
upon
on c5 he ended up being here
and it wasn't good
yeah i should have just taken right away
and on this i would have target against
this guy i'm still up upon in this
position in fact i'm up two ponds gotta
get this guy back
hmm
the decision to go here was not so wise
i was thinking the queen needed to take
but king h6
ah
missed opportunity i think
i really liked what i got out of this
opening
though hmm
what can you do
i'm going to try this again that's for
sure if the computer plays this this
idea of getting in the e4 pawn break
i've tried other stuff with the bishop
coming out here but very little success
yeah and right here the light square
bishop exchanged it avoids the knight
would have been too much of a beast on
that e6 square
could be defended with knight here but
he was a very awkward piece it's not
really a good choice for the black side
had the bishop pair
if i could do it over i would definitely
i would definitely play this position
again
more vulnerable king
i'm going to be up a pawn in this
situation c5
ah
i should have went with this instead of
queen here
oh well well it was a better
more quality game that's for sure than
the five minute ones but uh
okay that's all the uh that's the only
one i'm gonna do i'm not gonna play
another one for right now but as always
i hope you got some not something out of
this video and it was maybe a little bit
of fun to watch okay take care bye
you